il y a 6 ans
mon mari et moi-même avons été
doublement heurté
d'abord physiquement par un monsieur qui
roulait à contresens sur l'autoroute
puis éthiquement
quand nous avons compris que ce monsieur
habitait en France depuis plus de 50 ans
sans savoir parler la langue de son pays
comment est-ce possible aujourd'hui
comment supporter
d'entrer si peu en contact avec son
entourage
j'ai presque envie de dire comment
accepter de vivre autant à contresens
n'ayant pas envie que de tels événements
recommencent nous avons cherché la
meilleure manière de répondre à ce
ensemble
comment lever des blocages
pour que chacun puisse trouver sa place
bien sûr nous avons tout de suite pensé
à l'éducation
l'école a souvent ce rôle de baguette
magique et pourtant rien qu'à voir ce
monsieur des nœuds subsistent
nous avons donc ouvert en 2018 une école
alternative
l'objectif est de s'adapter aux besoins
de l'enfant afin de défaire ce fameux
nœud
nous avions en effet une conviction
chaque enfant
quel que soit son adresse quel que soit
son origine peut faire des étincelles
ce soir
j'aimerais vous livrer quelques pépites
des recettes simples qui nous ont permis
de défaire ces fameux et de renverser
complètement une situation
vous avez du mal à me croire
laisse-moi vous raconter cette première
histoire
Youssef est arrivé dans l'école
calme silencieux
introverti presque asocial
d'une extrême sensibilité
il se passionnait pour la crucifixion du
Christ et la morbidité
dans notre école encore nous commençons
et terminons la semaine par un
rassemblement une sorte de rituel pour
se retrouver tous ensemble et féliciter
les élèves méritants
cette fois-ci
Youssef est appelé
Youssef cette semaine j'aimerais vous
féliciter pour votre attitude vous venez
toujours en aide auprès de vos camarades
et votre comportement profite à toute la
classe bravo pour votre générosité
grâce à son comportement Youssef a le
droit de baisser les couleurs de l'école
puis il retourne en silence à sa place
au milieu de ses camarades
nous n'avions pas compris à ce moment
qu'il était bouleversé
une fois dans la voiture de sa mère
il faut en larmes
maman c'était incroyable maman tu sais
pas ce qui s'est passé
depuis Youssef communique avec tous ces
camarades
il avait un nœud dans son ventre qu'il
faisait vivre en nous parlant de la
cruauté sur la planète
mais grâce à l'influence d'un
environnement positif
un environnement dans lequel nous
prenons le temps d'entrer en contact
avec l'enfant d'avoir un contact
oculaire tous les jours de le regarder
régulièrement dans les yeux de lui dire
tous les matins bonjour Youssef quand il
arrive dans l'école de prendre le temps
de déjeuner avec lui il savait qu'il
était attendu
il savait qu'il était important à nos
yeux il savait qu'il avait une très
grande place dans cette micro-société
l'élève méritant était le coup de grâce
pour faire tomber sa carapace
la tension qui passe par du contact
oculaire
a donc de l'importance pour avoir de
l'impact sur un enfant c'est la base
pour le mettre en confiance
en 1981 de neuroscientifiques Hubert et
Wiesel on fait une drôle d'expérience
ils ont caché l'oeil gauche d'un petit
groupe de chatons
ce qui a provoqué l'atrophie de la zone
occipitale droite mots le plus compliqué
ce soir dans mon Ted
c'est à dire la zone qui synthétise les
stimulations visuelles
la nature ayant horreur du vide elle
supprime ce qui ne sert à rien
autrement dit ne pas stimuler le regard
d'un enfant par du contact oculaire gêne
le développement de son cerveau
alors bien sûr quand je parle de
simulation visuelle il ne faut pas
entendre écran
les écrans sont excitants il s'agit plus
d'une pollution que d'une stimulation
à part quand on parle quand c'est pour
regarder un TED on a fait une couper le
micro là
mais les écrans ne remplaceront jamais
le contact d'un humain
c'est pourtant ce qu'a cru la maman de
Fatou
laissez-moi vous raconter cette deuxième
histoire
Fatou est arrivé dans l'école une boule
de vie
incapable de fixer son regard
incapable de répondre à une question
elle n'avait que 4 ans
pourtant son histoire est simple et
courante la maman débordée a laissé ses
enfants devant des écrans
le regard l'attention le langage de
Fatou était donc resté en mode zapping
Fatou ne fait que reproduire ce qu'elle
a appris aucune attention tournée vers
elle donc aucune attention tourner vers
l'autre les autres
Fatou dans l'école
ne répond pas à nos questions ne fait
rien de ce qu'on lui demande s'échappe
de la classe cours dans tous les sens ne
joue pas avec sa camarade elle ne se
socialise pas
notre travail avec cet élève sera le
même qu'avec les autres enfants la
regarder droit dans les yeux
la voix un contact oculaire régulier et
lui donner des exercices adaptés
petit à petit mais à tout petit pas son
attention progresse et passe de 3
secondes à 6 secondes
et c'est peut-être là une nouvelle clé à
retenir ce soir
ne regardons pas ce qu'on ne sait pas
faire un enfant mais regardons ce qu'il
peut faire
trois secondes d'attention
merveilleux potentiel pour faire
progresser un enfant
je reprends mes deux neuroscientifiques
de tout à l'heure Hubert et wizel ils
ont fait la même expérience mais cette
fois-ci sur d'autres chatons en cachant
l'oeil droit d'un groupe de chatons ce
qui a provoqué l'atrophie de la zone
occipitale
ah super non parce que pour ceux qui
suivent pas il y a un contrôle sur
l'influence de main
qu'est-ce qu'on ferait pas pour avoir de
nouveaux élèves
bien sûr la nature ayant horreur du vide
elle supprime à la supprimer la zone qui
ne sert à rien ceci montre à quel point
le cerveau peut s'adapter à partir du
moment où on s'adapte
dans le sens où
la tête du chaton marche très bien il
s'est parfaitement bien adapté
là où il y a une décision défaillance
c'est dans l'environnement
il faut trouver la défaillance dans
l'environnement
cette expérience montre aussi à quel
point
tout se passe pendant la tendre enfance
la période d'incubation forte de la
connaissance se passe pendant la grande
genèse de l'enfant d'où l'importance de
la maternelle d'où l'importance de la
primaire parce que c'est pendant ces
moments de grâce qu'un enfant peut
rattraper tout son retard
d'où l'importance de la stimulation par
de la vérité
pas de beaux paysages sur un écran mais
des feuilles mortes dans la forêt
pas de courses de voitures sur un des
jeux vidéo mais une balade en
trottinette
je vous parle du cadre qui a son
importance mais il y a aussi
l'environnement la discipline
Maria Montessori disait
sans discipline point de liberté
mais un abandon de l'enfant
et sans liberté point de discipline
mais que de la soumission
ceci montre à quel point le cerveau peut
s'adapter à partir du moment où on
s'adapte à l'enfant
cette histoire me fait cette expérience
me fait rebondir sur une troisième
histoire
qui s'est passé dans une autre école du
réseau
quand tiguida est arrivé dans l'école en
6e en CP à 6 ans elle ne savait pas
faire la différence entre le son a et le
son I
les volets sont fermés en permanence
et la seule lumière provient du grand
écran de télévision constamment allumé
pour un enfant
la maîtresse a dû faire un travail
minutieux
vertu pour stimuler l'oreille de tigida
par de la manipulation par de la
répétition par du jeu
quelques semaines plus tard quand Tikida
a appris la joie du dessin elle traçait
de grandes lettres qu'elle prononçait à
voix haute
Tikida a fait un excellent CP
voilà un exemple d'un environnement
qu'on peut adapter
le cadre
a donc son importance à partir du moment
s'adapte à celui de l'enfant
Boris
de la résilience
nous dit qu'il faut organiser le monde
extérieur pour charpenter le monde
intérieur ce qui ne veut pas dire donner
beaucoup de liberté ou sur stimuler un
enfant organisé le monde
organisé le monde extérieur pour
charpenter le monde intérieur
veut dire que un an un an un
environnement bien construit permet de
faire grandir un enfant
concrètement dans nos écoles nous
faisons attention à ce que les enfants
arrivent dans un milieu sécurisé qui
sache ce qu'il doit faire en arrivant
dans l'école
prendre son manteau et l'accrocher au
porte-manteau avec son étiquette
retirer ses chaussures et les mettre
dans son casier avec son étiquette
prendre son atelier qu'il a lui-même
préparé sur son plan de travail
la veille
c'est beaucoup plus sécurisant que
d'attendre passivement qu'un adulte
s'occupe de lui l'enfant devient acteur
de son propre cadre
les rituels la discipline le contact
oculaire l'attention le potentiel de
l'enfant prenne du temps
rien ne se fait en claquant des doigts
prendre son temps prendre le temps de
regarder un enfant permet de remettre de
l'espoir en lui permet de lui redonner
de la confiance
alors je vous dis qu'il faut prendre le
temps et pourtant il y a bien une
ambivalence à ce sujet
il y a une urgence éducative dans les
quartiers plus question de prendre son
temps à ce sujet
d'après l'INSEE en 2019
le taux de décrochage scolaire en France
et de
8,7%. c'est à dire des jeunes qui sont
sans emploi sans
diplôme et non scolarisé
ce taux passe à
13% pour la ville de Reims et à 32% pour
un de ces quartiers
soit un enfant sur trois qui est sans
diplôme sans emploi et non scolarisé
c'est ce qui aurait pu arriver à la
maman des logos
laissez-moi vous raconter cette dernière
histoire ce soir
la maman des logos ça a grandi dans un
de ses quartiers
et c'est à tout prix ce qu'elle veut
éviter ce soir
éviter pour sa fille pourtant
quand elle est arrivée dans l'école en
CM2 et logosa n'aime pas lire et logo ça
ne sait pas lire
quelques semaines plus tard
la maman revient nous voir très émue
comment se fait-il que la matière
détestée de ma fille soit devenue son
loisir préféré le weekend
et logo ça lisait deux livres par
semaine
l'enseignant a fait attention à lui
donner des exercices adaptés adaptés à
ses besoins
et il a planté son espoir en elle
je pense même qu'il en a fait un défi
personnel
ce soir
je vais je vous ai donc raconté des
histoires d'enfants
qui ont plus grandir grâce à des
recettes de grand-mère des recettes
d'antan
et qui marche encore
la passion de transmettre et de partager
des savoirs à des plus jeunes
et j'en profite pour louer ce soir tout
le travail et tout l'engagement des
enseignants
prendre le temps
la gestation la maturation du blé la
queue à la CAF prennent toujours le même
temps il n'y a pas de raison pour que ça
cesse ou que pour que ça s'accélère pour
notre cerveau
et enfin le plus important pour moi la
tension
prendre le temps de regarder un enfant
de partager ses émotions de lui donner
de l'espoir de lui faire confiance
alors de la technologie de la tech de la
data de la cybercommunication il est
bizarre de faire un TED sur des méthodes
ancestrales et qui marche encore et qui
encore de l'influence sur nous
et c'est même bizarre de vouloir changer
des gens avec des méthodes aussi simples
en fait c'est comme roulera contre sens
[Applaudissements]